okay friends put your bets down who do
you like in this next fight this 15
pound Terrapin in Africa's Lake
Tanganyika who's looking for fish eggs
or the parents of those eggs never
underestimate the wrath of an angry
parent the Terrapin is shot down he
tries again rejected the Terrapin is
starting to get a little annoyed yeah
he's not gonna take that from a couple
of fish the cichlids have just begun to
fight it's their offspring they're
protecting and that's that first they
bite and then push comes to shove
and then shove turns to launch as these
feisty fish make their message clear get
out of town buddy the Terrapin is so out
of here